[Music]
with Oprah and I was like wait who's
Oprah what what does she do well he's
only nine so we'll give him a pass that
is a wrinkle in time starred Eric McCabe
making that Oprah confession to me out
of the premiere and now I have a little
confession of my own I was a bit envious
of Oprah's glamorous transformation in
the build so lady OHS glam squad turned
me into my own version of a mystical
missus so here I am in the complete
before look but I'm about to get my
wrinkle in time on so ignore my wrinkles
makeup master Derrick Rutledge who
transformed Oprah beautifully into mrs.
which came to et to work his magic on me
he's gonna make me look like Oprah did
you don't get my Beyonce I'm gonna give
you a version of Oprah from the movie
okay okay it's a two-hour process and
it's all about the eyes Oprah wore a
glittering assortment of jul 2014 we
decided to go without them so now I got
him oh my gosh just I totally feel
magical and mystical makeup department
head Lillet Little John created all the
colorful looks Reese's mrs. whatsit
Mindy mrs. who and I am missus wet get
it that's wh eg for Entertainment
Tonight I love it
I like being mrs. wet that's my alter
ego from now on and the look was topped
off with a curly wig ready for the
reveal ready for the reveal
mrs. wet shall we call it Oprah I think
we should see what she thinks over I
don't know if you can handle it
are you ready I'm ready no see okay
[Music]
what do you think oh my love the lips
hey mrs. which gives you my thumbs up I
love it
[Music]